[Music]
here we go okay 2026 april 1973.
okay we're sticking with e4 we're
sticking with e4 okay french so let's
play
let's play mainline you know we
we've been playing e5
exclusively
for the duration of the speed runs i
want to you know i want to vary it up a
little bit
actually you know what let me introduce
you to the terrace variation i what i
actually play myself is knight d2 this
is the torah variation i'll talk about
it more
thoroughly after the game
now the basic idea of putting the knight
on d2
as opposed to putting it on c3 because
what should probably jump out at you if
you've never played this before is that
you're blocking in your own bishop like
why would you do that well the reason
you would do that
is that you can meet c5 with the move c3
and you can keep your center intact so
in a way you kind of get the best of all
of the worlds you get to develop your
pieces and you get to keep your center
intact and the other knight is going to
be responsible for defending d4 now this
line has an interesting history
for many years for many decades 92
was considered automatic here it was
thought that the move knight gf3 which
may look more natural
is inferior and yet we're going to play
it that changed about 25 years ago
when you know computers came around
and
people started to figure out that knight
gf3 is
perhaps more testing
than the move 92 and queen b6 is the
classical old line this is the reason
why
uh people in the old days thought that
knight gf3 was bad because
simply you have a hard time defending d4
but then computers came along and asked
a very interesting question what happens
if you don't defend d4 at all if you
simply sacrifice that pawn and in return
you get a lead in development more space
and a clamp on the center with a pawn on
e5 so black is going for the line we
take on d4
and now without this next move white's
entire position would collapse because
right now the bishop is hanging the pawn
is hanging so we play knight f3
now if you if you're an e4 player you're
probably familiar with
certain very i mean this is not the only
variation of the french
where you give up the d4 pawn far from
the only one i mean the milner berry
gambit there's a bunch of lines where
you sacrifice the pawn on d4 but here we
have to follow up
very accurately otherwise black is going
to consolidate we're going to have no
compensation does anybody know
what the main move is here for white our
opponent clearly knows this he's playing
quickly
what is white's best move
here yes queen a4 is correct you have to
stop the knight from coming to c5
and of course this deploys the and
it prepares to swing the queen over to
the other side of the board queen g4
becomes a serious idea so serious that
we're gonna play it right now queen g4
attacking g7
obviously black cannot castle
because that runs into bishop h6 winning
the exchange
and if black plays g6 we can still
put our bishop on h6 in fact we will do
that you know we've got very serious
control over the dark squares bishop f8
well that's a pretty serious concession
okay so this is one of those positions
where
nothing happens fast here it's white
we're not gonna mate black in like three
seconds
what we're gonna do is mount a slower
campaign that's based on
massaging
the weak dark squares
and getting our rook into the game
getting our other rook perhaps to e1 in
order to over protect the e5 pawn so
there's there's like a lot of ways that
we could handle this position we could
take the bishop right we could take the
bishop we could keep the bishop and drop
it back to g5 although i don't really
like that because then black and fiance
if we are to move the bishop we should
probably move it back to e3 because
that's a tempo move other than all of
that
the move that i really like
yeah queen f4 queen g5
looks pretty good
but if we play queen f4 then black might
have this move
queen b4 well actually then we have
queen c1 let's go for it let's go queen
f4 and we got to speed up a little bit
here i took a while on this move
yeah b2 is hanging
b2 is hanging but we're happy to
sacrifice
that pawn
right in in these lines you have to be
ready to sacrifice two sometimes even
three pawns in order to
maintain
your control over the position in case
he doesn't take on b2 i will show you
after the game sort of
approximately what i intend to do after
queen takes b2 and i don't know yet well
actually now i do i think there is a
very interesting move after queen takes
b2 and probably our opponent is thinking
about it right now whether to take that
pawn yeah knight g5 i'm trying to make
that move work
by the way that is a threat knight g5
attacking f7
is a serious threat here
yeah no this is
this is juicy
notice why are we even
keeping the tension
well the reason we're keeping the
tension we want that queen on h6 we want
to prevent black from castling if
possible
although if fleck does cancel it's not
the end of the game i mean
we can still play knight g5
this is not a position
that i would recommend
for you know
12 or 1300 with white because it is
very very difficult this is among
the most difficult types of positions to
handle where you've sacrificed
not just any pawn but a center pawn
that's passed and
your compensation is positional it's not
like you're
immediately attacking or there's an
obvious
set of moves that leads to mate right
you're just sort of massaging the
position slowly
you know finding in little inroads ways
to
keep the initiative going and even for
gm's these positions are very hard to
handle queen d8 okay
so this is a perfect opportunity for us
to bring some pieces into the game you
can't play these positions unless you're
patient and unless you understand that
where does the compensation come from it
comes from
you know our superior piece activity
so
the no brainer move that we should play
here is rook a to c1 this stops knight
c5 confining the knight to d7
obviously the c file is very important
it's the only open file as i've said
many times during the speedrun games
when there is only one open file you
want to make sure if possible that you
are the one who controls it
and this is a classic example of
how effective that control can be
because if black plays queen e7 then we
will immediately infiltrate to c7 so we
have i think a very cool idea here this
idea is
i wouldn't necessarily call it typical
but it exists in positions where
you know your opponent has
all of the pawns on one color like this
we want to try to chip away
at black's pawn shell right black's pawn
cover is the only thing that is holding
our pieces back from breaking through
one idea that's very straightforward is
to double on the c file rook c2 on rxc1
and then trying to double uh get into c7
but
the move that i really like is h4
we're trying to get this pawn down to h5
why are we trying to do that well the g6
pawn is our primary target
if we play h5 and black ignores us then
we will take on g6 fg6 and bishop takes
g6 with devastating
effect black is ignoring us let's go h5
chipping away
chipping away
at black's pawn cover
this should make sense like without me
even over explaining this knight c5 now
it's time for some tactics now your
first instinct should not be let's move
the bishop your first instinct should be
let's calculate h takes g6 and try to
make that work
let's try to calculate that so
hg6 let's say that black takes the
bishop okay
because if ht takes g6f takes g6 then we
have bishop to hg6 so h takes g6
knight takes d3
then we can play
g takes f7 check
but we can also play the move g7
ooh and g7 is really juicy yeah g7 queen
h7 that's got to be the way bang let's
go
g7 queen h7 because that actually
attacks the knight and it attacks the
rook so worse comes to worse
we reestablish material equality but
let's not rush i think we might have a
better move
i am very attracted to queen g7 here
actually i'm very attracted to queen g7
because after rook f8 which is forest
we play gh
knight takes c1 rook takes c1 and we can
basically promote at our leisure
i'm pretty sure
oh but he has king d7
oh he's got king d7 that's annoying no
no let's let's stick to g7
it was worth exploring but i think we
should stick to this queen h7
okay so king e7 is annoying
but we're just gonna have to deal with
it
there's there's so many like i wish we
had more time here because there's so
many juicy options to explore and
instead we're just going to end up
playing very technically here
yeah so here like for example we have to
take here
and then black takes here and
we're winning this because the king is
in terrible shape and the bishop is bad
but this will take some more finesse
okay so now i think it's a perfect
opportunity
for us to think about doubling on the c
file but also queen oh queen a3
queen a3 looks like a really juicy move
yes we're playing queen a3 without even
thinking
we are making our way into d6 into the
mouth
of madness
and queen e7 is i i had a feeling that
black would do this and this is the
point that i've been making
consistently as we hit 2000 which is
that when you're like 1300 you put a
little pressure on your opponent they
collapse at this level
people still collapse but
that collapse comes later right you have
to put a sustained
you know 10 15 moves of serious pressure
on somebody before they finally make a
blunder and i think we saw that very
clearly here this is a
an elementary blunder rook c7 is
hopefully an idea that everybody is
familiar with winning the queen
bang
and it's
mate to follow the other rook comes out
to c1
yeah this is
a pretty nice technical game good
illustration of
the power of this line by the way okay
wait let's not yeah roxy one okay okay
and remember that when you are trying to
win such positions efficiently
do not get tunnel vision in regards to
checkmate right remember that you can
use the weakness of the king in order to
win
a bunch of material now in this case we
actually have checkmate but a good move
would have been to play queen f8
but in this case or rook takes c8 queen
d6 check leads to immediate checkmate if
you calculate it this is made in three
or maybe made in four
and he resigns yeah king a8 rook takes
bishop okay
that was a nice game
all right so this line is called tarash
it's named after zigbert
zigber tarash
who was top five in the world
for sure
um in the in the late uh 1800s
so zigbertarash was born born 1862 died
in 1934
german
and he was not only influential as a
player he was a
you know an opening expert and he wrote
a lot and he had very strong opinions on
how chess should be played and how chess
should be taught
and the way that chess history is
usually presented i don't know how much
of this is like 100 it's not cut and
dried but it is said that tarash butted
heads with nimsevich and people who
pertained to the hyper-modern school
like tarash believed that you had to
control the center you had to play
traditionally you know the sicilian was
bunk
he was very
old school but he was also very good so
the this idea that people seem to share
that tarash was just a loser who
you know was dogmatic and
you know adhered to the old rules that
nobody you know
he was like the luddite he was the guy
who's the flip phone everybody had
smartphones that's not totally true
because he actually beat the crap out of
nimzovich like a gazillion times so and
out of a lot of other people
so taras was really good
and
you know you you don't just like
stumble into having
topical lines named after you that are
still being played today
so 92
trash decisions start decisions so 92 is
the second most popular move after
knight c3 with the advanced variation
clocking in at number three
and
well as i explained the idea of putting
the knight on d2 is actually very very
simple knight c3 has the
serious drawback of allowing bishop
before this is the win over variation
knight d2 takes the sting out of
all of these shenanigan type moves
bishop b4 now is totally ineffective due
to c3
and the secondary reason is that you are
unblocking the c pawn
in the event the black content or the
black challenges your center as black
did in the game
we can play the move c2 c3 in order to
support the d4 pawn
so knight f6 is one of two
main
responses to the terrace the other is
the immediate c5 in the modern day
people go knight gf3 here there's a lot
of theory
we're not going to talk about this right
now
so knight f6 e5 knight d7 this is
super super old theory this has been
around forever c5 c3
obviously similarities to the advanced
variation
and after knight c6 we reached like this
fork in the road the move knight gf3
has been around for a very long time in
fact
a little historical detour let's see
when the first time that this position
occurred was i wonder if it was before
1900 or after 1900 so the first time
that this position was drum roll please
oh it was eight the first three times
that this position occurred was tarash
altaresh 1890 1891 1892
how about that you know that doesn't
just have an alakan played it tarash
played 92. in fact everybody played 1992
the first guy to play knight gf3 was a
guy named israel horowitz very strong
international master in 1938.
everybody had been playing 92 until
horowitz and assignment oh no pollock
william henry pollock in 19 in 1891
played knight she f3 and lost and the
second guy to play knight g3 was frank
marshall after whom the martial chess
club is named but you can clearly see
how chess understanding has grown
because in the martial game in this
position he played the move queen a4
which is
which is not considered good anymore but
you could see that in like the 30s
the idea of sacrificing the d4 pawn here
would be
that just
wouldn't
cross the radar of most players even the
strongest attacking players like
marshall so 92 is not a bad move right
92 and 93 are about equivalent according
to theory
the reason that everybody played 92 is
because after queen v6 you have the move
knight f3 and you can support the pawn
on d4
most people didn't want to play knight
g3 precisely because of queen b6 now
the theory of this line has
ballooned and now black has a gazillion
moves here there's g5 there's just
bishop b7 there's a5
the queen b6 is still considered to be a
very reputable variation
okay
so
we sack on d4
we get the knight out to f3
we force the queen back we go queen a4
to tie down the knight and prepare to
deploy our queen to g4 the main move
here is actually queen before which i
mean the queen trade is is is out of the
question for white because we're down a
pawn
so we drop back to c2
now the old school variation goes queen
c5 offering another queen to another
you can make a draw with quinn a4 but
queen e2 is the more combative line
finally black develops the bishop
so does white
the queen moves back to a5 and you get
essentially a position like this
which the engine generally evaluates is
approximately equal
but black is just so cramped i love
playing these positions with white i
feel like white's having all of the fun
here
um although wesley wesley crushed me
in in a rapid game in one of these one
of these lines like wesley just got all
his pieces out and i had to resign
because i was down upon anyways i you
know the speedrun isn't really about
delving into openings in particular
this is something that you could
investigate on your own if you are
interested in
like the theory of this line and you
know exactly how
the competence where the compensation
comes from you can look this up using
opening explorer and stuff so in the
game oh i apologize
in the actual game
he played bishop e7 which is a move
which is a movement as it is a bunch of
games in the database queen g4
but generally black wants to avoid
having to play g6 in these positions
castles i can probably show the wesley
game let me see if i can find it
yeah i played very poorly against
against wesley in this line
i just let him i somehow let him get all
his pieces out
in the meantime yeah so here bishop h6
and
you don't even have to take the rook i
mean you can do our idea with h4h5
yeah so g6 bishop h6 is kind of
automatic
and i still see two games in the
database after bishop f8 oh netive 2482
grand master
so a bunch of
bunch of people have this position okay
i think i found the wesley game yes i
did
slightly different variation
a little bit different but you can still
you'll get the point
you can see the board okay so this is my
gaming it's wesley
2015
rapid online game
so
yeah so we had this entire thing going
on
and then
okay he went for a slightly different
version of this but we basically got the
same position
but it's a worse version for white
because you can't bring the queen to a4
and that was really really tilting to me
um so i just kind of like okay i played
bishop e3 wesley with goes knight c5
very high level move pinning his own
knight
but the point is that the knight is so
well protected by all of black's pieces
that you actually cannot easily put
pressure on it
so i gave a check he covers it
notice that wesley does not mind taking
back with the king just because
the king on d7 is perfectly safe it's
sheltered
by this little pawn cover that's
impossible to bring down
knight before he takes it he castles
i i was making like all of the moves i'm
supposed to make but
at this point i was just like okay i'm
down upon i have nothing for it bishop
h6 is no longer dangerous for black
because of bishop f8
and he just ends up killing me here
queen a6 unpinning bang
sacking the exchange
and pinning my own bishop distracting
the queen taking the pawn
i mean
this this game wasn't even close
he just played perfectly i reside in
this position yeah wesley on a good day
is honestly just like a literal engine
it's crazy
rookie two knight c1 by the way traps
the rook so i resigned
but in any case like you should be very
careful when you play this line with
white obviously you should try to know
you should know like all the details
back to the game
after bishop f8 we decided to
keep the tension with queen f4
and this is i think a very serious
mistake by black
um players at this level as i've
explained many times struggle to keep
the tension
and
this just gives white's queen prime real
estate penthouse manhattan penthouse
overlooking central park and this is the
square that the queen
is coveting so bishop takes h6 is a very
i mean it's it's it's a move that lacks
lacks resilience you know what i'm
saying
so instead the move that got me worried
and it still has me worried is queen b4
using the bishop to offer a queen trait
and if queen c1 who can tell me how
black can continue harassing white's
queen what's the same
move with the same idea
after which i think a draw is pretty
likely
yeah queen c5 do you see what the point
is the point is that the white queen has
to remain pegged to the bishop but
whichever square the queen goes to
whether it's d2 f4 or even g5 black's
queen has a corresponding square
on which you can offer a queen exchange
now i will say that trading is not out
of the question here
maybe you can go for this type of
position and maybe you can argue that
even in the end game
white's control over the dark squares
and black's passive pieces
give white
good compensation for the pawn
maybe maybe not i'd be reluctant to go
into an end game like this i mean
extra pawn like this in the end game is
it's a big big deal
so
i think we before would have led to
perhaps a repetition was instead we
trade on h6 and this is where things go
completely downhill for flight queen d8
i think this is another bad move
if you ask me the way that i would
handle this with black is i would make
it a priority a top priority
to try to either get the queen out of h6
so maybe still queen before in queen f8
or
or at least
try to get
your pieces out of their unbelievably
passive squares go knight c5 and go
bishop d7 at least try to get your stuff
out
we had a couple of questions about queen
takes p2 i don't really have a clear
answer for you other than that i was
planning a move like rook ac1 i was just
going to
keep
bringing pieces into the game
these pawns are irrelevant
and oh and the other idea that i had to
to make this move knight g5 work now if
you go knight g5 prematurely who can
spot
black's incredibly annoying
defense
black has a move that
you know that calls the cops on the
party that we're having yeah that's
knight takes e5
no it's not f6 if you play f6 you you
white breaches the
you know
black's position springs a leak once you
take on e6
but the problem is knight takes e5 so
thinking logically you can say okay
why is knight 65 a thing well it's a
thing because the queen also defends
that pawn so let's try to force that
queen off of this diagonal let's try to
make it take on a2 and now we can go
knight g5 and this is crushing
if bishop takes h6 then obviously
this is checkmate
now the issue is that it's not so simple
because
black does not have to cooperate
and black can play the move queen c3 but
now we can keep the same process going
with rook b3
again i don't want to like
delve too deeply into this position
because it it gets a little boring
i think people get the point the point
is just that white's
more we have more active pieces black's
position is riddled with weak pawns and
a weak king
and all of those things put together
give white
compensation for the pawns i think
compensation that concept is very poorly
taught because a lot of people who teach
it
make the concept of compensation sound
like some mystical thing that ogms kind
of can just tell when you have
compensation and regular people can't oh
there's nothing about white's
compensation that should be mysterious
you should see it visually now in some
positions compensation can be hard to
evaluate properly like the amount of it
but this is not one of them
anyways bishop h6 queen h6 queen d8
we deploy a rook to c1
after a6 like i said there are many many
good ways to
to to enable to to handle you know
handles position but
we decided to apply this very classic
idea
of of h4h5
i think this idea is very clear we are
using our pawns
in order to
completely destroy
black's pawn cover so that our pieces
can then infiltrate more effectively
i think a lot of people here
would be tempted to play queen g7 but
are you really telling me that the best
you can do is spend two tempi and take
the corner pawn on h7 now you could say
well it's not so much the pawn that i'm
taking i'm preparing to sacrifice the
bishop on g6 and then i'd say you're
making a good point
but i'm not sure that this is the most
effective
use of your resources black and play
queen e7 and the second g6 looks pretty
lackluster here
so i think h4 is very thematic
and very very strong b6 h5
and if black takes on h5 then we can
already consider the move knight
g5 with the very nice tactical detail
that if black now takes on e5
you have the move queen g7 for king
for king
forking the rook and the knight and if
knight takes d3 this is checkmate what
was black's plan with b6 uh
my guess is that he wanted to play
bishop b7 and rook c8 to contest
uh to contest the c file but
you know this is a runaway train on the
king side we're already crashing through
completely
takes
and here i'm sure the engine will laugh
at me and find something a lot better
but we decided to win back the night
and i mean this position is just
just miserable for black
probably the most resilient move is king
e8 here
and
make no mistake the game goes on i mean
material is equal
black does have the g file so
this is not over i mean we're much much
better here no question about it but
queen e7 was total collapse
rook c7 and it's all it's all over
okay i think this was a good good little
illustration of the tarou's variation
it's a very dynamic line
if you want to learn this you definitely
need to study
this line very very carefully
i'm going to leave you with that thanks
for hanging out guys and i'll see you
guys later
[Music]
you